this virus is costing us more than lives
so much of our work and leisure has
slowed or stopped
the price we're paying is enormous as
the second wave arrives
the government says protecting life's a
priority
but measures that protect life threaten
the economy
and they're expected to save that too
would the prime minister reassure
us all and my constituents in north east
derbyshire the primary focus the
government remains on protecting
both lives and just as importantly
livelihoods
yes indeed mr speaker my honourable
friend can certainly reassure his
uh constituents some are skeptical that
the pm can do both and want him to
prioritize the economy
the scare tactics being used and under
regulatory actions taken
will have an immediate impact on high
streets the hospitality industry
and further devastation for the aviation
industry everybody should look at the
what's already happened in the first
phases of this pandemic
have been in no doubt that it is
possible that such a thing
could happen again and it's precisely to
avoid that
that we are taking the steps now that we
are because a stitch in time
saves nine and there'll be far more
damage to the economy
throughout our country if we failed to
control
the virus now this leader holds a
different view and worries economic
concerns are compromising the effort to
save lives
we mustn't be hamstrung in essential
public health decisions
by the lack of necessary economic
mitigations
and there is a danger that what starts
to hold us back
is not the public health analysis but
financial limitations
so i'll be writing to the prime minister
today and i hope
constructively because i recognize that
the economic implications of all of this
for the treasury
are not easy nicholas sturgeon wants
even stricter rules if she could she'd
like to close all bars restaurants and
pubs
in scotland but that comes with a price
tag you'd have to extend
the furlough scheme and it's already
cost the british taxpayer an eye
watering 39
billion pounds and as for mr johnson he
does want to try to
save lives now but he doesn't want to
ruin them in the future
by destroying the british economy the
labour leader wants a more
joined up approach different leaders of
different nations have gone
in different directions do you think
boris johnson went far
enough there are obviously different
rules now in england scotland and wales
and
one of my criticism of the prime
minister is that he hasn't held the four
nations
um together barely had meetings with the
leaders in the devolved
administrations and it would be far
better if there's one set of rules
across the whole of the united kingdom
the furlough scheme you want more
support for people
if they can't get back to work as the
government is introducing new
health restrictions it's phasing out
economic
support businesses now as the result of
these new restrictions
are going to be put under huge strain
and you owe it to them to put a support
mechanism in place so the government
really should have done that yesterday
they may do tomorrow an economic
response being worked up by the prime
minister and his
chancellor who will set out a new plan
to try to protect jobs
but the autumn budget now cancelled as
the government braces for more economic
turbulence
ahead beth rigby sky news westminster